welcome to python tutorials with simply
learn so let's begin
before we move ahead let's have a look
at everything that you learned today
so first we look at what exactly these
tuples are to what is a variable
and finally what lists in python r so
let's begin
what are tuples a tuple is a collection
of
immutable heterogeneous python objects
so the extra term that comes in case of
tuples
are that they're immutable so over here
we have a tuple
that's x and within x we'll store
various
elements 1 89 a single letter a
which is a string also a word which is
again a string in python hey
o and b so as you can see this tuple
here
may not be necessarily completely filled
with integers
completely filled with floats or strings
it can be a mixture of all of these data
elements
so that is one advantage we have when it
comes to tuples and lists
as compared to arrays because with
arrays you can have only one data type
elements within it
now we look at indices so every element
in a tuple
takes up a position and this position is
what we refer to as an
index in plural that's indices so
tuple's
positioning or the indices for tuples
and list strings
also in case of python and most other
programming languages
starts with zero so your element one is
at the zeroth position your element 89
is at the first position
and so on where b is at the fifth
position so in a way you can say
that the length of your tuple x is six
but then the last index of your tuple x
is five because it starts from zero
onwards so now that we have a basic idea
of what a tuple
is let's begin with creating tuples
creating
tuples now the first thing that we are
going to do is we will create an
empty tuple so say my empty tuple's name
is emp
all you have to do to create an empty
tuple is give these curved brackets with
no elements inside so this is a lot like
list
but in case of lists we had square
brackets in this case we have
curved brackets so that's the only
difference now if i print the type
of emp you'll see it's a class tuple i
can also print out just
emp and since emp is an
empty tuple there's no element within it
but then of course
the brackets are still printed because
that's a list
because that is the basic characteristic
of a tuple so even if it's
empty these brackets would still be
existing
so we saw how to create empty tuples but
how often do we actually use empty
tuples so let's put some elements into
our tuple
so let's start with creating a tuple
with just one element so say my tuple's
name is city
and i'll have one element pune if you're
creating a tuple with one element
if you're not putting the bracket it's
completely valid
as long as you have a comma after that
particular element
so with this kind of a syntax you can
create a tuple so i'll create a tuple
say city and i'll just have one element
within this
which is pune now if you're not putting
this element within these curved
brackets that's very characteristic to
tuples
it's completely okay while creating a
tuple as long as
you have a comma after your element so
although you have no element after this
comma
that one single comma is important so
let me run this
and just type of city as you see city
has been stored as a tuple
now in the most standard way of creating
tuples you'll say
city and within brackets you'll pass
your element
also print out city after that and this
same syntax can be used
and then you can also combine these both
although that's completely unnecessary
effort but it's possible
it does not result in an error so you
have your brackets and the comma
works just fine now i want to add more
elements to city because clearly pony is
not the only city we know
so pune bangalore these are some of the
cities
in india if you're from another country
and wondering
so after this demo you not only know
tuples you also know a few cities
in another country so i have four
elements in this tuple and this is how
you create it all the elements separated
by commas and within brackets
print out city now i can do the same
thing without the brackets too just the
commas
indicate that this is a tuple now those
are the various ways you can create a
tuple
of course all these ways do not come
handy usually you use this method to
create a tuple with
n number of elements and when it comes
to one element you usually go for this
just put one element within the brackets
this is also used sometimes now another
thing we saw
while learning what a topolous or
looking at the definition of a tuple
is the word immutable so we said lists
are mutable which means that they can be
changed and tuples are immutable
as in they cannot be changed so here
we'll see a small example
as to what the difference between tuples
and lists are when it comes to the
execution of these both
so say i have a list list 1 and that has
elements 1 2 3 4
and then i have a tuple say tuple 1
which has the same elements
1 2 3 and 4. now with list 1 i'll use
this method that you
probably have encountered before called
append so i say list
dot append of five so what this function
does
is it adds five at the end of this list
which is list one
now we'll print out list one run this
code and as you can see here 5 has been
concatenated to our list 1. now let's
try the very same thing
in tuple so tuple 1 dot append
5 and i'll run this and see you get an
error here so the tuple object has no
attribute append in fact it has none of
the functions which you usually use
with lists because these functions aim
at changing the original list and not
giving back
a new list in tuple's case you cannot
change the original list
once your tuple is set that is how it's
going to be
as long as it exists so that is the main
difference between lists
and tuples list is mutable whereas tuple
is immutable and other than that of
course you must have noticed the
syntactic difference
which is lists are with square brackets
and tuples
may or may not use parenthesis or the
curve brackets
so every time you print out a tuple or
you view a tuple
it's always got those brackets but as
you saw while creating a tuple sometimes
a comma is enough
so now let's access these elements in a
tuple if you want to print out the
entire tuple
we already saw just put it in a print
statement put the tuple list
put the tuple name in a print statement
and you'll have your tuple printed now
if you want to access some particular
element of the tuple
say i want to take out bank lock so in
that case we use the indices
as we saw earlier indices start from
zero and
bangalore is therefore at the first
position so i have to just say
city and within square brackets one so
this particular line or the syntax is
exactly the same as you would use for
a list or string just run that and here
we go we have bangalore now
we can also extract elements from the
end of the string just like we did
in case of list so if i do not know the
length of the string now suppose i want
to access the very last element of my
tuple but i have no clue as to what the
length of my tuple is
in that case what index do i use well i
can just go with minus one
now every time you give this minus sign
it starts accessing elements from the
end of the tuple
so minus one means the first element
from the end of the tuple which is
mumbai
and that's what we got as our output now
although lists are immutable
there are a number of operations you can
still perform on them for example
the very first thing we look at is
concatenation
so i already have my tuple city we'll
just print it out once again here
to see what it consists of now we'll
create another double
say num and this will have the elements
one two three four
now sure i can't modify tuples but i can
definitely concatenate these two so how
do you do that
extremely simple city plus num the plus
sign
works perfectly fine for concatenation
so i will print this out
and we have an error here that is
because we have not
compiled our num list first so our num
list is not
existing right now i ran my line 19 now
i can run the next line we have one
complete list which has all the elements
of city followed by the elements of num
now you can also nest tuples that is you
can have one tuple within another tuple
so so far we have a tuple city and
num now i will create another tuple so
first
now we already have a tuple city and num
what i'll do
is i'll create a new list say nest so
this is going to be a list
so we have our brackets here so what i'm
going to do is i'm going to create a
tuple within another tuple so we have
a new tuple i'll call it nest and since
this is a tuple
the basic syntax i'll have the brackets
now what will be the elements within
this
the elements would be my other two
tuples which are city
and num so i put in both my elements
here and
let's see what nest contains now so nest
is a tuple
which itself contains of other tuples
which are city and
num so that is how you nest tuples
extremely simple isn't it
now here's something else say i want to
create a tuple
rep which has an element python but that
element
is repeated five times so what you would
generally go for
is type out python five times but thank
god for python there's a much simpler
way of doing this
type in python once and multiply this
five times let's print out rep now and
as you see here python exists within
this tuple
five times one two three four five now
maybe this is not how you want to create
your tuple
you want your tuple to just have that
one element python
initially but later on while printing
you decide you know what i want python
to be printed
10 times within this tuple not a problem
put your tuple name here
and then go for it into 10 and as you
see here
the tuple has now 10 elements within it
so guys remember when you're putting the
statement here
it's not actually modifying the tuple
it's just printing it this way
so if i say rep once again and i run
this this tuple just has one element
so next we look at slicing in tuples
so we created our tuple num previously
i'll just print that out once again so
it has the elements one two three four
now suppose i want all the elements from
two
up to the end of this tuple to be
printed in that case
what i do is i go for slicing where i
will mention my beginning and my end
index
so my beginning index starting from 2 is
of course 1
and my end index is basically the
position 4 is at or to the
end of this tuple now when i want all
the elements up to the end i do not need
to mention my
end index it's by default taken so so if
i just say num
of 1 up till black run this
your tuple sliced it gives out the
elements at the first
second and third position considering
zeroth
is our first position of course now you
can also print
this num tuple in reverse using
these indices so you say num i leave my
start
and end index empty give two colons
and then in the end i have minus one so
when you put this minus one here so it
basically prints out the reverse of your
tuple
let's check that out and as you see your
last element is now your first
element and your first element is now
your last element if you have any doubt
regarding how slicing works
please check out our video on python
lists over there we have a detailed
description on how slicing is
and there will be no confusion since in
case of slicing at least
tuples and lists are exactly similar
so let's look at the string that i have
here simply learn now i want every
letter of the string
simply learn to be an element of a tuple
how do i do this
well pass the string as a tuple so write
tuple
off and within this you have your string
which is again within quotes
right we'll run this command and as you
see here every character
is now a separate element in a tuple so
this procedure is called unpacking
now i'll just print out my num tuple
once again
so we can see what's in it okay so i
want to put these
elements which are inside a tuple into
various variables
now in this case i know that my tuple
has four
elements so i can have four variables a
b
c d and i'll put this equal to num
run this and then i'll print out a b
c and d so every element of the tuple
has gone into one of these variables the
first element went into a
second element into b and so on now what
if we had no clue how many elements are
there
in num in that case i could say a i want
my first element to go
into my first variable a no matter what
and i want my last element
to go into this variable c no matter
what now all the elements in between
i'm not very concerned about where they
go so in that case i can have another
variable b
but this variable will be a list so the
star indicates that b
is a list and then this is equal to num
we print out
a b and c so you see what happens here
is my first element went into a and my
second element
went into c because these were clearly
indicated but
every other element in between went into
my list
b so that is how unpacking works so
since tuples are immutable
it's impossible to delete the elements
within it but that does not mean you
cannot delete the tuple entirely
so that is what the dell keyword does
we'll implement this
so i'll create a tuple tuple 1 and put
some elements into
it one two three four now i'll use the
del keyword
now i'll just print out this tuple so we
know it
exists and what all elements are within
it so great our tuple is created it has
the elements one two three four within
it
now i'll use the dell keyword to delete
this tuple so i say
del space followed by your tuple name
run this command
now let's try printing tuple one once
again
of course since we did it all right
hopefully this tuple should not exist
and this should result in an error and
it is resulting in an error it says
tuple 1 is not defined so you can
completely delete the tuple
if not delete elements within the tuple
so as i mentioned previously
most of the methods that you have with
lists does not work with tuples
because these methods change the
original list itself but there are a few
built-in functions which do work with
tuples
they return values or new lists and they
do not
have any impact on the original tuple so
it works just fine
we'll explore some of these built-in
functions
i'll continue using the tuple i created
before that's num
so i'll create a new tuple num1 which
has the elements
3 five say four twos
six five eight and now we'll perform our
built-in function operations on this
num1 tuple so the first one that we look
at
is counting the number of occurrences of
a particular element
so that is the count function so you
give your tuple name
dot count off and the element whose
count you wanna
know so i want to know the number of
twos in my tuple num1
run that and as you see there are four
twos now you can also find the sum of
all the elements within your tuple so
that is sum
of num1 you just have your function sum
pass num1 to it now this sum function
works for tuples lists everything it's
not a function
particularly for tuples as such so the
sum of all the elements within our tuple
is 35
and in a similar way you also have the
len function which is in fact
even used for strings so len of num1
gives the number of elements within num1
which is 9 we have 9
elements but remember our last index is
8 not 9. our element is a2
coincidentally
now we have the max function for finding
out the maximum number
in your tuple so say max of num1 which
is 8
and we also have a function for checking
the minimum
of the numbers within our tuple which is
2 in this particular case
so now list and double are very similar
in the sense of what they hold
so what if i have a list say lsd which
holds the elements one two three
four and i want to convert this list to
a tuple
so we'll see how that is done first i
stored my list
one two three four so i'll just check
the type of
the variable lst ensure that it's a list
which it is
now we can convert this to a tuple so to
convert this to a tuple
enter your variable name and then pass
your list name
within these braces for the method tuple
run this code
and now let's print out tpl and as you
see our list
lsd has been converted to a tuple we can
also check its type
so yeah a conversion has worked out fine
now this kind of a situation often
arises when you
put certain elements into a list so you
create a list
that you desire and then you realize
that you don't want this to be
changed at all throughout the program so
then you can convert the list to a tuple
you cannot convert a tuple to a list
though so we previously
saw how we can have nested tuples that
is tuples within tuples now we can also
have
tuples within lists so we'll check that
out now
see i have a list lst and within this
list i'll define my tuples so two of the
elements of my list
lst will be separate tuples i have a
tuple one
two three and i'll have another tuple as
the second element of my list
as four five six so i'll run this code
print out
lsd so lst is created just fine it's a
list which holds two tuples
now tuples are immutable but lists
are mutable so we can add as many tuples
as we want
inside this list so we can make
modifications to the list
so i could say list dot append and to
this
i'll pass another list which has three
elements
say tuple inside
list from this code now if i print out
list
you'll see that the third tuple has also
been added to the list
now we can also remove tuples from the
list just use the remove function
so lst dot remove and within this i'll
pass the list that i want
removed which is my first list in this
case so run that code
and print out the value of lst to check
what's in it
right now so our first list has been
removed now we just saw how you can nest
tuples within lists now we'll check out
how we can nest
lists within tuples so i'll create a
tuple tpl
and within this tuple i have two
elements each of the elements being a
list
so they have a b c in my first list
and d e f in my second list
run this and print out the value of
tuple before we proceed
yeah so that's our tuple with two
elements each element a list
now we cannot modify tuples so initially
when we had tuples within list
we could add more tuples to that
particular list but now we have lists
within tuples
and we cannot add more elements to this
already defined tuple
but what we can do is we can modify the
list within the tuples so i can add
elements to the first element and the
second element
of my object tuple so i'll try that out
if i say tuple 0 dot
append so when i say tuple 0 it's
accessing the first element of the tuple
and the first element of a tuple is a
list so to this
i can use the append function and i'll
append
an element z run this code and then
check out the elements within tuple
and in the similar manner we can also
remove elements from the list within
this tuple
so i can say tpl of 0 dot remove
z and then print out tpl so you see z
has been removed here
now just for the sake of it let's see
what happens when we try to add
another list to this tuple so i say tpl
dot
append and pass a list x
y z and then print out tpl
so we get an error because this time our
object was a tuple
not a list and tuples cannot be changed
so with that we saw
the many concepts that is used with
tuple along with what tuple
is we'll quickly now have a very short
exercise
where we'll recall some of the concepts
that we previously saw in this video
so what is this exercise that we're
planning on doing we'll initially create
a tuple
which has the digits from zero up till
nine called tuple 1
and then we create another tuple by
adding an element to this tuple 1. so we
are not adding
an element to tuple 1 and modifying the
original tuple but we are creating
another tuple using the elements in
tuple 1 and adding another to it
then we'll create a tuple by adding the
reverse of tuple 1
to this tuple so first we have tuple 1
which has all the elements then tuple 2
which has all the elements of tuple 1
plus another number and then we have
tuple 3 where we have all the elements
of tuple 2
plus the reverse of tuple 1. so let's
move on back
to the jupiter notebook i'll create my
tuple which is called series
0 1 2 3 4 5 six seven
eight nine so that's my first tuple and
i'll print this out
so tuple's created next thing we do is
we create a second tuple which is series
one
now series one will have all the
elements
of series plus another element which is
10
so how can we add another element to a
tuple
if we are using so how can we add
another element to this tuple without
manually typing it out
now as we saw previously we can
concatenate tuples so we can say
series 1 equal to series and we'll add
the second element
as an element of another tuple so
instead of just saying
10 which is not possible because series
is a tuple
and 10 is an integer we can say a tuple
which just consists of ten
run this code and print out series one
so we have successfully been able to add
another element
two series and create another tuple
series one now we have to create a third
tuple series 2 which will have all the
elements of series 1
plus the reverse of series so again
we're going to use concatenation to
bring both these tuples together
say series 3 equal to series and of
course i can just say
series and plus but just for the sake of
recalling once again
how slicing works so i'll put an 11 here
and now to that i'll add the reverse of
series and not series one so i'll just
make this correction in the previous one
it's supposed to be series 1 here and
not
series and here i need to reverse it so
as we previously saw
i'll put minus 1 here and leave the
beginning
and end indexes empty run this
and print out series three so we have
all elements
of series plus the 10 which makes up
series one
and then the reverse of series so here's
a very simple statement
x equal to hundred a variable's
definition
is basically an entity of a program that
holds a value
so in this case x would be our variable
and 100 would be the value it holds
to better visualize this statement let's
consider a box
now if this box holds a value say 100
then the
name we give to this box which in our
case is x
would be the variable name and 100 that
is a content
within the box or within the variable
would be the value of the variable
now this is the basics of what a
variable is as we'll go through the
various topics today
you'll have a better understanding of
why we use variables and how to use them
so let's move on to the next topic which
is the various data types of variables
before we move on to this let me explain
to you what data types are
if you have dealt with other programming
languages before you probably already
know what data type is
but just in case you haven't data type
is basically
the type of value that you assign to the
variable so in our previous example
where we said
x equal to hundred in layman terms 100
is a number so the data type would be
number
but when we come to programming
languages there are two types of numbers
there are integers and there are floats
integers are basically numbers without
decimal point
floats are numbers with decimal point
other than this a very common data type
that we have
in python and other languages is string
so string
is any word in technical terms we call
them a collection of characters
python also has a few of its own data
types as we will see
so let's move on so i'll move on to my
jupiter notebook
so the first data type that we'll be
looking at is integer
as you saw in our previous example x
equal to 100
is an apt example for this let me run
this statement
as you can see there's no error that
means this assignment
is proper now we'll check the type
of this variable so type and within
bracket
you enter x run this and as you can see
the type
is int so int is the short for integer
any number without a decimal point comes
to end in python
now this is not the only way you can
assign values to variables you can also
assign values to variables while
simultaneously performing
arithmetic operations on them so 654
into 6734
enter now let's check out the type of
this variable
which would be int again now if you
print the value of this variable
you'll see that the value x stores is
the product of these two numbers
so now let's move on to the next data
type which is float
x equal to 3.14 as you can see this is a
number with a decimal point
if you run this there won't be any
errors so this is a proper assignment
statement
you print x
and the value is printed now you
print the type of x
run and it's float we'll move on to our
next data type which is strings
so string is any word it's a collection
of characters
so x equal to and within quotes so i'll
type simply learn
and run so no error
print x and the value of x is printed
which is simply learn
so guys whenever you're assigning
strings to a variable it's important
that you do them within quotes
now you can do them within single or
double quotes
i'll show you how it's done within
single quotes
and the exact same output so it does not
matter whether you use single or double
quotes
now let's check out the type of this
variable
type x and str which is a short form for
string
so now that we had a look at integers
floats
and strings let's move on to some of the
data types specific to python
the first one we look at is list so a
list is basically a collection of values
so far we assigned a single value to a
variable
with lists we can assign multiple values
and this is how it's done so give the
variable name
equal to open square brackets and within
this you type your values
so 14 67
9 run this no error
now let's print x and see what this
results in as you see when you print
x all the values you stored within it is
visible now let's check out the type of
x and the type is list
now with list since there are multiple
values stored within a variable
you might be wondering how you can
extract a single value
so this is simple each value in a list
has an index so you always start with
zero
this is the zeroth position first
position
second position so if you want to
extract
14 then you type print
x 0 and that will display
14. if you want to print the last value
print x 2 because we start from 0 so
this is 1
and this is 2 so that should print 9.
great now we'll change the values which
are stored within
the list so if i say x 2
which right now is 9 but i want to
change this
to 67 so that is a simple statement how
you can do so
and run now let's see what x holds
so when you just type x you're printing
every value within
x and when you give a particular number
within the square brackets with
x you're printing the value at that
particular location
so print of x run and as you can see
here guys
previously x held 14 67
9 now it holds 14 67 and 67 again
because we changed
x of 2 to 67 so now that we are done
with list
we'll move on to another data type in
python this is called
tuple so with tuple 2 it's about the
same thing
you can store multiple values in a
single variable
the syntax for doing so though is
slightly different
with tuples so instead of square
brackets you now have
round brackets and within that you type
in your values
so i'll just put 4
8 6
[Music]
and let's print x
so all the values within x is printed
now let's check the type of x
and the type gives double so you might
be wondering what is the difference
between list and tuple now the code
difference between list
and tuple is that tuples are immutable
so what i mean here is that in case of
tuples 2 you
access each value within it in the same
way you do
with list so if i want to access the
value 8
in x right now i'll just give x
within square brackets 1
[Music]
print this
and it outputs 8. but now
if i want to change this value so the
way of doing that
as we saw with list is x of
1 and the value i want to change it to
so let's say 5 and i run this
we get an error so you cannot change the
values in case of
tuples once you have stored the value
within the variable for a tuple
it remains that way right in the end and
in technical terms
this means that tuples are immutable
while lists for which you can change the
values they are
mutable so now we have something
slightly different
when we deal with files we need a
variable which points to a particular
file
so in general these are called file
pointers
the advantage of having file pointers is
that when you need to perform various
operations on a file
instead of providing the file's entire
path name or the file's name
every time we can just assign it to a
particular variable
and use a variable instead so this is
exactly the advantage variables have
with all
other values too but the syntax for
doing so with files is slightly
different
so i give x equal to open and within
brackets
open quotes enter your file name so i
want to open
say a file called variable underscore
com and this is ipy and b
so it's my python notebook and the mode
i'd like to open it in
so r let me run this no error so it's
fine this kind of an assignment
is completely legit now we check the
type of
x so as you see here
the type for x is underscore io.text
io wrapper so in
python this is the particular type
assigned to this variable
but in general terms you can refer to
them as file pointers
now suppose you want to assign values to
multiple variables what you can do here
is instead of having statements like x
equal to
5 enter y equal to 10
enter z equal to 7
instead of having three such statements
delete open bracket x y
z within bracket equal to
5 10 7 and this works
exactly the same so now if you print
x y
and c
[Music]
you'll see that they have been assigned
their respective values
of course the number of variables and
the number of values on either side
should match so if you put x equal to y
so if you give x comma y equal to
5 7 this would result in an
error because you have only two
variables on your
left hand side while you have three
values on your right hand side
now suppose you want to assign the same
value
to multiple variables in that case you
can do
now suppose you want to assign a value
to multiple variables
say x equal to 1 y equal to 1
z equal to 1. a short form to this as
you saw previously would be
x comma y comma z equal to 1 comma 1
comma 1
but then again you will have to type the
same value three times
instead what we can do is x equal to y
equal to z
equal to one and this would work
perfectly fine
so if i print the value of x y and z now
they all have the value 1 stored within
them
so we have covered the various data
types in python
and how you can assign values to a
variable in multiple ways
we'll next move on to the various rules
for naming the variables
now there are certain rules that you
must follow while naming the variables
we'll go through each of these rules and
simultaneously i'll also demonstrate to
you
in our notebook the validity of each
variable
so our first rule is variable name must
begin with an
alphabet or an underscore so let's move
on to a notebook
so abc equal to 100
this should be valid because it starts
with an alphabet
at the same time underscore abc would
also be valid
so if the variable starts with an
alphabet or an underscore it's a valid
name for the variable
but if we say 3 a equal to
10 this would result in an error
of course because the variable name
starts with the number and this is
invalid
same way we cannot start the variable
name with the special character other
than underscore
so if i say add the rate abc this would
also result in an error
as you see the error is invalid syntax
because that is the invalid syntax
for a variable name let's now look at
the second rule for naming variables
the first character can be followed by
alphabets
numbers or underscore so our first
character must be an
alphabet or an underscore and after this
first character we can have
alphabet we can have numbers or we can
have underscore
so back to our notebook by the second
rule
a hundred
should be valid as it is and if we put
underscore
which is a valid starting character
a 984 so our first character is followed
by
a letter three digits and then another
underscore this
should also be valid because at the end
of the day it only consists of numbers
letters and an underscore however
if a variable name is a 9967
few digits and then a dollar sign
would this work well no this would
result in an
error invalid syntax because as already
mentioned
for variable names the only special
character you can use
is underscore what about x y
z hyphen 2 again this would be invalid
because it
includes a special character that is not
underscore
can't assign to operator let's have a
look
at our third rule variable names are
case sensitive
so what case sensitive means is that
small letters and capital letters
are treated differently so let's move
back to a notebook
and say i assign a value 100 to a
variable
a 100 small a and i
assign another value 200
to a different variable capital a
hundred
so as you see here guys between these
two variables
the only difference is that the first
variable has a small
a and the second variable has a capital
a
let me just execute this if i print the
value of
a hundred and
capital a hundred you'll see that both
these variables are recognized as
completely different variables
they have the individual values so now
that we established that variables are
case sensitive
we can also say that python itself is a
case sensitive language
now our final rule is that reserved
words cannot be used as variable names
now if you have gone through any other
languages like
c c plus plus java you know this is a
common rule
among all of them you cannot use words
which have special meaning to the
language
as variable names so some of these words
are break
class try you have other words such as
continue
while which is a loop or if which is
a statement a conditional statement so
let's go back to our notebook
and see how assigning values to these
reserved words can result in errors
so if i give break equal to
10 that would be an error
similarly class equal to 5
would result in an error
try equal to 100 would also result in an
error
because these words break class try have
special meaning to python and with that
we cover the various rules for naming
variables
the next thing we'll check out is the
arithmetic operations that you can
perform on these variables
once you have stored integer values in
them so perform various arithmetic
operations with variables that store
integer
or float values so let's have a look at
some of these operations that we can
perform
we'll start with initializing two
variables so
x equal to 20 and y equal to 10
and now we'll perform our operations
with these two variables
so first let's check out how addition
works
result equal to x plus y so result is a
new variable
and it should store the value of x plus
y let's print this out
and as you see x plus y equal to 30. so
now result stores
30. similarly we can perform subtraction
we'll print this out too
so 20 minus 10 is 10
we can also perform multiplication
we use asterisks for the multiplication
sign
so 20 to 10 that's 200 next we'll check
out division
so as you can see here in case of
division the result is not an integer
but rather a float
if you want your result in integer what
you can do
is instead of putting just one slash you
can apply two slashes
so x slash slash y
and print the result and there you go
now you have the resultant integer
so in this particular case since 10
completely divides 20
the requirement of the double slash is
not very visible
but if we do division for numbers that
do not divide each other completely
for example if we have result equal to
2 by 3 and we print the result
we get 0.66 and so on
but if we give double slash here
and run this we get the result as zero
so in a lot of cases
the result from double slash makes way
more sense than from single slash
so this is an extra benefit you have
with python which is not present in many
other languages
we also have the modulus operator here
which gives the remainder rather than
the quotient
so if i say x mod y
it'll give me the remainder of the
division from
x by y and the remainder is 0 because 10
completely divides 20.
on the other hand if you do want to see
the remainder you can
give numbers such as 3 by 3 more 2
and then print the result and as you see
the remainder of this operation would be
1.
now so far we saw arithmetic operations
with integers
all these operations can also be
performed with floating point numbers
so if your x value is 3.14
and your y value is 5.7
let's just perform one operation using
the new values of x and y
to see what it looks like
so let's say result equal to x by y
print result
and there's your quotient so arithmetic
operations work both with integers and
floating point numbers
next let's check out some of the
operations you can perform on string
variables
as i mentioned earlier strings are
basically a collection of characters
so let's look at a few string operations
first we'll initialize
a string variable so var equal to
simply learn and we'll perform all our
operations on this var variable
now the first thing we'll do with this
string variable is we'll see how we can
extract each character in string so just
like in case of list
and tuples every character in your
string
has an index and it always starts with
zero
so the first character is at location
zero
second at one third add two and so on
so if you want to extract the first
character of your string which is
s in our case we just do
bad or zero and as you see
s is printed similarly if we want to
extract the fifth character of our
string
we'll put var of 4 so if you want to
extract
n character your index for it would be n
minus 1 because we start our index from
0
and that prints l so as you can see here
s is 0
and then we have 1 2 3 4 and that is
l so now that we learned how to extract
a single character
let's see how we can extract multiple
characters from the string
suppose i want to extract the first
three characters
in that case i would say bad of the
first three so my starting character
would be at zero
so if i want to extract the first three
characters of my string
what i'm basically saying is that i want
to extract the character at the zeroth
first and second position then i'd say
print
off var of starting from the zeroth
location
up to the third location we say three
and not two because the last index is
always excluded so if i put 2 here
instead of
3 then only the 0th and the first
character would be
printed so i want my first 3 characters
to be printed
so var of 0 to 3 and i'll run this
and as you see the first three
characters have been printed capital
s followed by i m now if you want to
start from your first character
you can also just ignore the zero so you
can say var
of colon three
that is we are not typing the zero in
this case it's automatically
understood that you start extracting
from the first character when you miss
out the zero
so you run this and as you see it's the
same result
now if you want to print the characters
starting from the fifth location
until the end of the string you can go
with
print off var of fifth character so five
and up to the end in this case you do
not need to mention
the last index you can just leave it
blank and it's automatically understood
that you're printing till the very last
character of your string
and as you see from your fifth index to
the very last character has been printed
now suppose you give where of 0 to 20
and it's pretty obvious that you do not
have 20 characters in this particular
string
so you do not have 20 indexes so what do
you think would happen if i do 0 to 20
well the entire string is printed so
although we have only 11 characters in
our string
and we have given the ending index as 20
this does not result in an error
just our entire string gets printed now
if you want to find out the length of
your string without
actually having to count it manually you
can use the function
len of bad length is an inbuilt function
in python
now run the command and as you can see
we have 11 characters in our string
so those are the basic operations you
can do with a string variable
i hope this is very clear to you as in
the end we have a small
quiz which uses some of these concepts
so now that we have gone through the
various concepts of variables
let's have a small exercise where we'll
be using string variables
so we'll have two strings one string
says it's sunday
and the other stores have a great day
using
only these two strings we need to build
a third string which says it's a great
sunday so let's have a look at how to do
this
we move back to our notebook the first
thing to do
is we store our two source strings in
separate variables
so let's have variable var1 which stores
our first string
it's sunday
and we have the next variable var2
which stores our second string have a
great day
now using these two strings we create a
third string
which is bad three so first let's run
these two statements
so now vad 3 needs to store it's a great
sunday
the word it's comes from var1 so var1
and it starts at the first location so
0 which we can ignore because it's
automatically
assumed to be 0 and we require all the
characters in var
1 from the 0th position until the
position just before our capital s of
sunday
so that would be 0 1 2
3 4 so our fourth position
is the blank space since we want to
include the blank space 2
we give our ending index as 5.
now the next part of our string it's a
great sunday
needs to include a grate from where to
so var two
so the next part of our string is a
great
and a great comes from var2
now this subscript starts from the fifth
position
in wire two so our starting position
would be five
and at the 12th position in var2 we have
the space that comes after grade
now we need to include the space 2 so
we'll go with our
ending index as 13 and finally
our last word of it's a great sunday
which is sunday will come from var one
so var one and the word sunday starts
from the fifth
location in varban so our starting index
here would be
five and we'll take the entire string
from the fifth location
so we leave the ending index empty and
that's it
so let's run this now let's just check
if what we did so far is correct so
we'll print var3
and yeah that's perfect as you can see
we have it's a great sunday
in bad three which is exactly what we
wanted
so now a short quiz for you so if you're
familiar with
other programming languages but for
those who are completely new to
programming languages definitely try
this out
so we have a variable a which holds a
value 100
and we have another variable b which
holds a value 200
now the task is we want b to hold the
value 100
and a to hold the value 200 so basically
you're swapping the values between these
two variables
so give this a thought and post your
answers in the comment section below
we'll give out the answers soon enough
and with that we come to an end of
python variables so what
are lists a list is a collection of data
and this data could be of any data type
in fact a list could hold data of
different data types
as we can see in our example down here
we have a list named
x and x holds 1 89
the single letter a the string hey
another number 0 and the capital letter
b now another important factor
with lists are it indices every element
in the list
has a position and this position is
called an index
the first position in a list is always 0
so 1 is at index 0 89 at index 1
a at index 2 and so on so this means
that the position of your last element
would be the length
of your list minus 1. so now that you
know what a list is
let's move on to how you can create a
list
so this is my jupiter notebook and we'll
start by creating the most basic
list which is an integer list so my list
name would be num
and then open square brackets and within
this
just put in your numbers separated by
commas
so that is my first list run this
and there seems to be no error let's now
print this list out just to see what it
looks like
and as you can see the elements that we
inserted in this list are printed
which are 1 2 3 and 4.
next let's create a list with just
single characters
so my list name is letter and the syntax
is exactly the same
you open square brackets and now that we
have
letters inside which are characters
you type these within quotes
let's print this to
and once again after the run you can see
the letters that we inserted into our
list
letter next let's create a list of
strings
so i'll name my list stg
square braces and again strings should
always be written within double or
single quotes
and that's my list of strings
i'll print this too great so now we have
created a list of only integers
only letters and only strings now as i
mentioned before
list can contain a combination of
different data types
so let's try that out i'll name my list
mix because it's going to be a mix of
number strings
two numbers and then i'll follow this up
with
a few strings
and let's run it so that works perfectly
fine
now lists have another format if you
have worked with any other programming
language
previously you would have come across
the term matrix
so usually in other programming
languages matrix
are associated with arrays so they are
basically 2d arrays
in case of pythons matrix can also be of
lists
so you can have a list containing two or
more lists
so let's do that i'll name
my list matt as in short for matrix
open square braces and since the
elements of this list
are also list put these two in square
braces
so our first list would be 1 comma 2
and then comma because our second list
is basically the second
element of our list mat and our second
list would be
a b and that's how you create a list
containing lists
so our parent list is mat and this
contains two lists
the first list is one comma two and the
second list
is a comma b so let's print this out
and there you go so we also created a
list
containing list so these are the
different type of lists you can create
next we'll move on to how you can access
the elements
within this list so there's no point of
creating a list if you cannot
access each individual element within
the list now here to understand how to
access the elements of the list
we'll be using the list mix that we
created previously
so before we start i'll just print out
mix
so you can have an idea of what is
inside
so we have five elements within mix the
first two
are numbers or integers one comma six
and that's followed up by three strings
simply learn get certified we previously
saw that every element
in the list has an index position so the
simplest way
of accessing an individual element in
the list
is by following the list name with
square braces
and within the square braces mention the
index number
of the particular element so if i want
to access the element
get my index would be 0 1
2 3 so mix of 3
and i'll run this we got our element get
now in a similar way you can also use
negative indices
to access the elements so when you put a
negative sign the indices are basically
counted from the back of the list
now if i want to access the same word
get but
all i know about this word position is
that it's a second last word in the list
i also do not know the length of the
list in this case
i can just say mix of minus two
so two as in it's the second last
element
and the minus signifies that you count
from the end of the list and not from
the beginning
so i'll run this and extracted get
now as you probably would have noticed
in case
of indices when counted from the front
of the list
it starts with zero on the other hand
when you count the indices
from the end of the list it starts with
-1 and not
0. so now we saw how you can access a
single element from the front of the
list and from the back of the list
now what if you want to access a range
of elements
say i want to extract the first three
elements of the list
mix in that case i could just type mix
again square braces and within here i'll
put colons
followed by three so ideally there would
be a number on either side of the colon
but in this case we are taking from the
beginning of the list
so if the digit before the colon is
supposed to be zero
you can just leave it blank and
automatically it's interpreted as
0 also we know that our third element
would be at the index position 2 but
here we have written
index position 3. this is because our
last
index positions always excluded so if
you give
2 instead of 3 then the only elements
that would be extracted would be the
ones
at zeroth and first position since we
want the element at the second position
2
we give the ending index as 3 so let's
print this
and we received our first three elements
of the list mix which are 1
6 and the word simply learn now what if
we want to
extract all the elements from a certain
position of the list
say our third index position of the list
up till the end of the list in that case
again we have mix square braces and we
have the same colons as
we used previously but now since we want
our starting index to be 3
we enter 3 and the element at the third
index would be included
but now we want to extract all elements
till the end of the list
so you can just leave the last position
blank
when you do this it's automatically
interpreted that you're taking
all the elements up to the end of the
list let's run this
and we received get and certified
now i want to extract the word simply
learn
and get from our list mix
in this case what would be the
parameters within our square braces
so simply learn is at the index location
2
and get is at the index location 3
so our starting index would be 2 but as
we already mentioned
previously if i put 3 as my ending index
i would not receive the element at the
index position 3.
therefore i'll put my ending index as 4
and run this and there you go we
received our two words simply learn and
get
now here's something slightly more fun
so what if i want to extract
every second element of my list in that
case i put two double colons
followed by two because i want every
second element of my list
and run this so as you see here one has
been printed
which is followed by six in our list
mix but six is skipped and then we have
simply learn
again the word get is kip and we have
certified
now there's one more thing you can do
with list indices
you can print them in the reverse order
so to do that just two colons
and minus one let's print that
and as you can see your list mix is
printed in the reverse order
so now if we go back to line 16
these two double colons are basically
positions
for your indices so suppose you want the
second
element from the first index and not the
zeroth index
you can write one here and if you want
every second element from the first
index up to say
the fifth index you can put five here
but in our case we did not have a fifth
index
so i'll just leave it at this you can
obviously try that out
in fact we'll be using a variation of
this in our exercise later on
so now that we saw how you can access
the various elements of the list
let's look at the various operations you
can perform on the list
suppose you want to create a list of a
hundred zeros
if we go by the traditional methods we'd
literally have to
type in a hundred zeros separated by
commas within the square braces
and this gets very tedious so a short
way of doing this
is type in that one element
that you want repeated multiple times
within your list
and outside the square braces follow it
up
with asterisks digit and the number of
times you want this element to be
repeated
so 0 into 100
and let me print this
and as you see a hundred zeroes exist
within
our list c now we can also create
a new list concatenating two or more
lists so let's create a list
concatenating the two lists that we
previously created
letter and sdj so i'll just print these
lists
out first
[Music]
that's our list letter
[Music]
and that's our list stg now we'll create
a new list
call con a short form for concat
and how do you concatenate two lists
well you just
add an addition sign between them so
letter
plus sdg and that's all it takes
to join two lists let's print out kong
and there you go so the first four
elements in our list con
is from the list letter and the last
four
elements is from the list stg
now there's another operation with list
called unpacking
so here you basically give a string as
an argument to this
function list and that unpacks each
element
of the string as a separate element in
the list
so i'll show you this with an example if
i name a list where
and list off within the brackets
i enter the string i say hey there
and now i'll print var
so as you can see every letter of this
string hey there
has become a single element in the list
var now let's check out another
operation
on list using the list num that we
created previously
so once again i'll just print num out so
we can recall what
was within it we had the four numbers
one two three four
now suppose i want the first element
of my list num which is one to be
in a variable one and i want the rest of
the elements
to be stored in another list called say
others how do i do this i can just put
1 which is my first variable a comma
and then star other equal to num
so what happens here is that the star
signifies
that every element that has not been put
into the previous variable or variables
is put
into this list other so let's print out
the variable 1 and the list other
separately
and see what they contain and as
expected 1 contains the value 1
which is the first element of our list
num
and the following elements of our list
which are 2 3 and 4
are stored in the list other let's now
look at a few methods
specific to list so for the following
few examples we'll be using
the list that we created previously
called num
i'll print the list out first so num has
the elements 1
2 3 and 4. now the first method that
we'll be using
is the append method and the syntax for
that is the list name
which is num dot append
followed by brackets and within these
brackets you basically
insert the element that you want to add
to the
end of your list so suppose i want my
list to be one two three four
six all i do is enter six here
and that should ideally add six to the
end of your list now
so now let's print out num
and there you go so previously our list
contained the numbers one two three
four and after we executed the num dot
append method
six was added to the end now what if we
do not want to add
a single element to the end of the list
but an entire
other list so in this case we can use
the method
extend the syntax for this is num dot
extend
and within the brackets you'll enter the
name of the list you want to add
to your previous list so here i want to
add the list
stg that we created previously to the
end of my list
num now before i execute this command
let me just print out sdg so we know
what's in there
so within sdg i have get certified get
ahead
i'll just delete this cell
and now i'll run the command so let's
print out
num and as you see
num previously had one two three four
six from here
and then we added get certified get
ahead
to the end of this list now now these
kind of additions only take place
at the end of the list what if we want
to insert an
element somewhere in between the list
for this
we use the method insert
and the syntax is your list name num dot
insert and within brackets you first
enter the position or the index at which
you want to enter the new element
so i want to insert the string simply
learn
just before get so this is my fifth
position
so my first parameter here would be 5
followed by
the element i want to enter which is a
string simply learn
so i'll type it within quotes
and let me run that let's now see what
num looks like
and as you see here we have one two
three four six
and then we have the new element that we
just inserted simply learn
followed by the elements which were
previously in our
sdg list alone now there's another
method you might come across regularly
which is the remove method so this
method as the name suggests
removes a element it basically removes
the first
occurrence of that particular element so
the syntax for this is num dot remove
and within the brackets you enter the
element that you want to remove so i'll
remove the element simply learn
and run let's now see what
num holds so as you can see
simply learn has been removed now if
there were two
occurrences of simply learn one here and
maybe one
after a head only this word would be
removed and not the one
later on because it removes only the
first occurrence of that particular word
or that particular element okay
so now let's create a new list save add
one
and we'll just insert a few letters in
here
now imagine you receive a list like this
where there are few elements but in a
jumbled order
you want to sort out this list one
simple method
sort is all you need to do bad.sort off
run it and now let's print out
what one holds so all your elements in
var1
are now sorted python also provides a
few built-in functions that can be used
with lists
so we'll have a look at the most basic
ones
so before we begin let's create a list x
and i'll fill my list with just integers
so that's my list and we'll use this
list throughout
all of built-in functions now the most
basic built-in function
and the most commonly used is len what
len does is it tells you
the length of your list so len of
x and the length is 6.
our next built-in function that we'll
try out is min
min gives you basically the minimum of
all the elements that's present in your
list
so min of x and the minimum element in
our list is 4.
similarly we also have max which gives
you the maximum
of the elements present in the list max
of x
which is 90. now we also have a function
sum which basically gives you the sum of
all the elements present in your list
so sum of x and that's 189
now in python we do not have a function
which gives you the average but it's
very simple to calculate this
we do so using the sum function so you
find the sum
and then you divide that by the length
of the list
so sum of x by len of x
would give you the average of x
so with that we covered the basic
built-in functions for python lists
we also cover the methods in list a few
operations in list
we saw how we can access the various
elements in list
so for our exercise we need to create a
list
of numbers from one to ten we'll call
this list
one and then we'll split list one into
two lists
odd which contains all the odd elements
of the list one
and even which contains all the even
elements of list1
so now let's move on to a jupiter
notebook and see how this is done
so let's first create our list1 which
will contain all the elements from 1 to
10. now you can use the traditional
methods
and enter all your numbers from 1 to 10
within these square braces separated by
commas
or we look at a simpler way of doing
this
you say list and to this you pass the
function
range and within range you specify the
range
of the elements you want within list one
so i want all
the elements from 1 up to 10 so my
ending index would be 11 and they are
separated by commas
let's run this and
let's print list one
and there you go so all your digits from
one to ten is stored within list one
now the next thing we need to do is as i
mentioned earlier we need to split list
one into odd and even
and odd list will contain all the odd
elements and even will contain all the
even elements
so let's start with odd
so my list name is odd and the elements
will be taken from list
one and now the tricky part how do we
specify the
indices in this case so if you remember
previously
we had gone through an example where we
want to access every second element
in which case our index was mentioned
like this where the two
indicated that every second element
would be taken from the list
so in this case two since odd numbers
occur after every second element
our interval is still two and we'll
start from the zeroth position of the
list
which is one and go up till the end so
this is our command let's see what odd
holds
and as you can see odd has all the odd
numbers from list one
now we need to store all the even
numbers from list1
into this list even
again our interval would be 2 but this
time
if we just skip every second element
from the beginning
even would have all the odd numbers
so what we do is we start skipping the
second element
from our second element so from index 1
onwards we'll start skipping every
second element
let's print out even and there you go
so our list even has the even numbers 2
4 6 8
and 10. so with that we successfully
completed our exercise
and we also come to an end to list in
python
if you have any doubts please post them
in the comment section below and we'll
definitely get back to you
please hit the like button if you like
the video also subscribe to our channel
as we have a lot more coming up this is
anjali signing off
see you all next time
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here